In this lecture, we'll discuss
how linear optimization
is used to design radiation
therapy treatments for cancer
patients.
Cancer is the
second leading cause
of death in the United States,
second only to heart disease.
There were an estimated 570,000
deaths in 2013 due to cancer.
Additionally, over 1.6
million new cases of cancer
will be diagnosed in the
United States in 2013.
These trends are also
seen throughout the world.
Worldwide, cancer is a
leading cause of death,
with 8.2 million deaths in 2012.
Cancer can be treated
using radiation therapy,
where beams of
high-energy photons
are fired into the patient
to kill cancerous cells.
This is a very common
form of treatment
for many types of cancers,
and in the United States,
about half of all
cancer patients
undergo some form of
radiation therapy.
Radiation therapy has a history
going back to the late 1800s.
X-rays were discovered by
Wilhelm Rontgen in 1895,
who was later awarded the
first Nobel Prize in Physics.
Shortly after the
discovery, X-rays
started being used to
treat skin cancers.
This image shows an x-ray
of Rontgen's wife's hand.
You can see the
bones in her hand
as well as her wedding
ring on her finger.
A few years later
in 1898, radium
was discovered by
Marie and Pierre Curie.
They won the Nobel Prize
for this discovery in 1911.
Radium started being used
to treat cancer, as well
as other diseases.
Later in the 1900s, the first
radiation delivery machines,
called linear accelerators,
were developed.
Then computed tomography, or CT
scans, were invented in 1971.
These discoveries
led to the invention
of Intensity Modulated
Radiation Therapy, or IMRT,
in the early 1980s.
The invention of
IMRT significantly
improved the ability
of radiation therapy
to target cancerous cells.
To reach the tumor,
radiation passes
through healthy tissue
and therefore damages
both healthy and
cancerous tissue.
This damage to
healthy tissue can
lead to undesirable
side effects that
reduce post-treatment
quality of life.
For example, blistering
and burning of skin
can occur because of the
damage to healthy skin cells.
For this reason,
we want the dose
to fit the tumor as
closely as possible
to reduce the dose
to healthy tissue.
This became possible with
the invention of IMRT.
In IMRT, the intensity profile
of each beam is non-uniform.
Before IMRT, each beam had
to have the same intensity,
so the tumor could not
be targeted very well.
But by using non-uniform
intensity profiles,
the radiation dose can
better fit the tumor.
Let's see what this looks like.
In this image, we have
a person's body outlined
in black, and then
the target, or tumor,
and two critical
structures also outlined.
We would like to maximize
the radiation to the target,
while minimizing the
dose to healthy tissue,
and especially to the
critical structures.
Using traditional
radiation therapy,
each of the three beams
has the same intensity
throughout the beam.
So to deliver enough
radiation to the tumor,
we also have to deliver a
significant amount of radiation
to the critical structures
and to other healthy tissue.
But by using IMRT, we
can change the intensity
throughout each beam
to make it non-uniform.
Some pieces of
the beam will have
a higher intensity than others.
This allows us to deliver the
necessary amount of radiation
to the tumor, while
minimizing the total radiation
to healthy tissue, and thus,
the critical structures
get significantly
less radiation.
Each of the pieces of the beam
is referred to as a beamlet.
So in IMRT, we
decide the intensity
of each of the
beamlets so that we
can target the
tumor with radiation
while minimizing the
radiation to healthy tissue.
So in designing
an IMRT treatment,
the fundamental problem is
-- how should the beamlet
intensities be selected to
deliver a therapeutic dose
to the tumor and to minimize
damage to healthy tissue?
This is the problem that
we'll address in this lecture,
using linear optimization.